dear chancellor merkel, welcome to
this house, which is the house of
european democracy, there are moments in
history that require vision and courage,
and this is one of them, that is why we
have your experience and your
german quality of forging consensus
beyond  particular interests to work
for the general interest of europe we must
be able to react more
quickly and more unitedly in the face of crises and
strengthen our
strategic sectors and our resilience as a
society I ask that in the next
six months we work side by side to
overcome  differences and divisions
between north and south between east west that we
strengthen our union for the good
of citizenship we show the world that it
is possible to create a fairer
sustainable society that thinks about the
environment and future
generations an egalitarian society
with women in  leadership positions in
all institutions a society that
values
policies  such as health
and education that protects
workers who demand
fair wages that values diversity and i
capable of managing migratory flows with
olidarity all of this is on
his agenda and he will count on us to wo
k in my political group together with
my colleagues from the spd have worked
on a roadmap towards a more effective europe that is
closer to citizens we
share european values let us al
o share our commitment to defen
them and make them a reality thank you very much
hank
you